The fallout from the Johnny Depp/Amber Heard
trial continues, and now its effects are even
reverberating…under the sea. Well, kind
of. Here's what fans have learned from
court filings about the behind-the-scenes
tension on "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom."
Things haven't been great for
the DC Extended Universe lately,
and the same can be said for "Aquaman and
the Lost Kingdom" star Amber Heard. After
"Blue Beetle" bombed at the box office, the
DCEU is riding a four-movie failure train
toward the "Aquaman" sequel. Meanwhile,
Heard has spent much of the last few
years in a series of highly public legal
battles with former partner Johnny Depp.
As the Snyderverse era is nearing its end, both
Heard and the DCEU would no doubt welcome a win.
However, potentially muddying the waters for
both is a new report by Variety, which contains
some serious and occasionally strange allegations
about the production and its treatment of Heard.
We should point out that the Variety article
doesn't contain direct quotes from Heard or
other named parties. Instead, much of its
information stems from notes that were
taken by her therapist, Dr. Dawn Hughes, during
sessions, as well as unnamed industry sources.
These files first surfaced on Reddit in September,
after Depp's fans paid for the release of court
documents. It's also worth noting that because
the article was published during the ongoing
2023 SAG-AFTRA strike, neither Heard nor Momoa
can currently address the allegations to
the press. This means that at present,
there's no way to know for certain what was,
or wasn't, said when these notes were taken.
According to the article's allegations,
multiple people behind "Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom"—including director James Wan—wanted
Heard out because of her legal battles.
"Sometimes you have to do what's right,
even if your heart aches against it."
The biggest bombshell in the new allegations
are the notes implying that "Aquaman 2"
star Jason Momoa wanted to get rid of
Heard and was very much against her,
to the point of taunting her while dressed
like Depp. These notes allege that Heard
described Momoa as, quote, "drunk, late
on set" and "Dressing like Johnny Depp."
"Don't! No!"
These allegations are in clear conflict with
earlier claims that Momoa fought to keep Heard in
"Aquaman 2." In all likelihood, we'll have to wait
until the SAG-AFTRA strike ends before Momoa's
people comment on the situation, but for the
time being, insiders have vehemently denied these
allegations, stating that Heard and Momoa had a
good relationship on the set. One source said,
"Jason works his ass off, likes to have
a beer once in a while like everyone,
but doesn't show up drunk to
set. And he isn't dressing
like Johnny Depp. He has always
dressed in that bohemian style."
A DC representative has also denied the
allegations and praised Momoa's professionalism.
Similarly, the studio has
also denied the allegations
against James Wan. A spokesperson told Variety,
"James is known for treating members of his
cast and crew with the utmost respect and for
fostering a positive, collaborative environment
on set — the 'Aquaman' films were no exception."
According to multiple sources, Warner Bros.
wasn't originally going to include Amber
Heard in "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom," citing
chemistry issues with Momoa. Strangely enough,
the notes allege that the reason she
ended up in the movie was none other
than Heard's former partner Elon
Musk, who contacted Warner Bros.
and threatened litigation should
Heard not be part of "Aquaman 2."
"I'm going to kill Aquaman
and everything he holds dear."
However, all of this reportedly happened in 2018
and was unconnected to the Heard-Depp trial.
Due to the timing of the Variety article, Momoa,
Heard, and other parties may only be able
to comment on the news extremely belatedly,
if at all. Musk hasn't shared his version of
the events, either. As such, there's a chance
that the notes and the allegations they contain
will resurface in the news somewhere downstream.